Herkese
[Müzik]
merhaba
konforunun oldukça yerinde olduğu
güvenilir bir adam vardı benim fakat
hemen yan odada hayatımın bundan çok
daha iyi versiyonu yaşandığını
hissediyordum içten içe
ben size gün bir gün oda Bugün diyerek
açmaya karar verdim duvarlarımı
anlatacağım
E Tipi Ankara çocuğuyum ben bolca devlet
memuru ve öğretmenlerden oluşan
kalabalık bir sülalenin çok sevip çok
sevilerek büyütülmüş biricik kızım bu
çalışan bir annenin çocuğu olarak Kendi
işimi kendim halletmeyi pek çok sorunun
üstesinden gelmeyi yemek yapmayı
kardeşimle ilgilenmeyi oldukça genç
yaşlı öğrenmek sorumluluk bilinci mi
hızlıca geliştirdi bi güvenilir bir
mahalle ortamında ip atlayarak Top
oynayarak pek çok yaş grubundan arkadaş
eş dost Konu komşu esnafla diyalog
halinde büyüdüm
bu ilkokul yıllarında Yazılanlara
bakılırsa hep Konuşkan minyon ve oldukça
hareketli birisiymiş
Şimşek akşamüstleri okul dönüşü Babamla
birlikte evimizin çok yakınındaki bir
Tuhafiye yoğuruyoruz sıklıkla sahipleri
Babamın arkadaşı onlar bir kenarda
sohbet ederken ben çoğunlukla tezgahın
arkasına geçip Olan biteni izlemeyi
seviyorum dükkanın sürekli birilerinin
girip çıkması oradaki sürekli değişim
bir inanılmaz heyecanlandırıyor şu
bu ne zaman ki çocukluğumla ilgili bir
anıyı düşünsem hep o dükkandaki olaylar
ve orada ne kadar mutlu olduğumu
hatırlıyorum
ailece birlikte sevgi dolu bir ortamda
büyümenin verdiği özgüvenle Sorumluluk
sahibi bir kadın olarak yetiştirildim
üniversitetercihleri sırasında
ve Düzenli bir hayat bir Düzenli bir
geliri seçmem için yapılmış tercihler
vardı yani benim neyi severek ve
heyecanla mutlu olarak yapacağıma göre
değil o zaman tercihlerimiz puanlarımızı
göre sıralanır the tamamen bunu odaklı
oluyordu
abone ol
bu
burada olmak gerçekten çok heyecanlı
daha önce hiçbir şeye benzemiyor emin
olabilirsiniz
[Alkış]
lisans eğitimi başladığımda da sınıftaki
pek çok arkadaşımdan farklı olarak asla
ve asla devlet memuru olmayacağım
konusunda oldukça Nettim matematik yarım
hiç iyi olmamasına rağmen bir şekilde
iki saat bölümünü kazanmıştım ancak ne
iş yaparak daha mutlu olurum sürekli
Bunun içerisinde dönüp duruyordum
birşeyin fiziken üretilip satılması bana
çok ilginç geliyor Örneğin bir çimento
fabrikası gördüğümde çok
heyecanlanıyorum bir imalathane
gördüğünde kalbim atıyordum biz bunları
gördükçe kariyerimi nasıl
şekillendirebiliriz mi Düşünüyordum ama
bir yandan da Aile içerisinde bana bir
dükkan açsak nasıl olur demeyin Öyleyse
korkuyordum Çünkü bizim ailenin genel
meslek tercihlerine bakılırsa bu durum
oldukça hepsi için şok edici olacaktım
şu kurumsal ve Global şirketlerin şaha
kalktı bir dönem yaşanıyordu haliyle
Plaza kadınlığı çok moda Şükrü piyesler
toplantıdan toplantıya koşma halleri
Hareketli bir hayatı sürekli çalan
telefonlar bu kariyer benim için uygun
olabilir diye düşünerek hayatımı Bu
doğrultuda çizmeye karar verdim ama bir
yandan da gözümü kapattığımda kendimi
sıcak samimi bir dükkanda hayal ediyorum
sevdiğim yiyeceği yapmış satış için
çıkarmışım bir yandan biraz sonra
uğrayan müşterimle sohbet edip ta ki
çocuğun kafasını seveceğim doğum gününün
nasıl geçtiğini sorun hoşbeş edeceğim
bunu düşünmek bana çok iyi geliyor dua
abone ol
Bu
da henüz lisans eğitimi biri bitmeden
kariyer basamaklarını hızlıca tırmana
bilmek için hemen gönüllü stajlar yarı
zamanlı İşler pek çok projeler bunları
yapmaya başladım Daha farklı
pozisyonlarda kendini geliştirir Sem
yeni yeni şirketlerde yeni yeni
pozisyonlarda aday olabilirim diye
düşünerek devamlı kendimi farklı
alanlarda farklı şirketlerde
geliştirmeye çalışıyorum ama bir yandan
da bu dönemde çok farklı bir alışkanlık
edinmiştim devamlı her şeyi planlıyordum
elimde birden fazla ajanda vardı Biri
günlük hayatımı bir sosyal hayatımı biri
geleceğimle ilgili yaptığım hayalleri
biri İş hayatım organize ediyordu ne
zaman ki planlarından biri Axa Örneğin
bir randevusuna geç kalsa veya
toplantılarından biri iptal olmak
zorunda kalsa İşte o zaman inanılmaz bir
panik mutsuzluk huzursuzluk yaşıyordum
Yani daha 25 li yaşlarında bir ve sol
delisi ve ajanda bağımlısı olmuştum bu
dönemde Kariyerim hızla devam ederken
bu aşk oldum
hayatımın Ben başka bir dönemine giriş
yaptığım hissediyordum ayaklarım yerden
kesildi Ve evlendim çok kısa bir süre
sonra için bebeklerimize hamile kaldım
Ben
her gün düşünürken
beni birilerine tane hayallerimi
anlattığımız sıralarda sürekli olarak şu
vardı aklımda Ben burada kendimi
gerçekleştiriyor şimdi bir hissetmiyorum
farklı bir şey arayışındayım başka
şeyler yapmam dedi gerekiyor böyle daha
iyi hissedeceğim istediği düşünüyorum
derken Hep bana dünyanın en iyi
şirketlerinden birimde çalışıyorsun
kariyerin Açık geleceğin parlak
bırakılır mı bu Konfor diyorlardı büyük
Konfor garantili gelecek temiz iş sahip
Olman gereken İhtiyacım olan herşeye
sahipsin Peki sahip olduklarını esir
misin yoksa onlarla Özgür müsün Hep
aklında bu soru dönüp duruyordum
gebeliğin boyunca a okuyup Araştırmaya
devam ettim kitap gibi düzenli çocuklar
yetiştireceğim düşünüyordum her sabah
vaktinde kalkacak benim onlar için
hazırladığım menüleri Yiyecek her gün
gelişimsel etkinlikler yapacak bu akşam
banyoları yapıp vaktinde uyacaklar da
çünkü ben böyle planladım ve Benim
planlarım asla Şaşmaz
ama gibi bilimin 7 ayında bazı şeyler
ters gitmeye başladım Çok ani bir
kararla hızlıca doğuma girmem gerektiği
Belli oldu Belli ki beklenenden oldukça
küçük doğacak Hatta bu uzun bir süre
yoğun bakımda kalması gerekecektir
çocuklarımızın
bir
iki üç gün içerisinde yapılan
kontrollerin sonucunda Aydan doğuma
alındı Ve bu durumda sadece ikiz
bebeklerimizi değil yepyeni bir belirli
daha doğurdum karnından çıkarıp bana
şöyle uzaktan şöyle bir gösterip her
yerlerini hortumlar bağlayıp hemen yoğun
bakım alanı aldılar çocuklarımızı bu
doğumdan Yaklaşık 15 saat sonra onları
görmeme iyi çizim verdiklerinde gördüğüm
manzara tanımı dondurdum ve hemen düşük
bayıldım
kücükler hareketsizler ve dokunmam
imkansız yani hiçbir şey benim
planladığım gibi değil benim onlar için
günlerce araştırıp en iyisinin en
kalitelisi olduğunu düşündüğüm
biberonlar yerine
biberonların delikleri oldukça küçük
olduğu için onlardan süt çekmeleri çok
zormuş çocukların Bu da kilo alımlarını
yavaşlatıyor Muş asla kullanılması
mümkün değil dedi hemşireler
en basit lastikten yapılmış
en son biberonlar vardı ellerinden düşük
doğum ağırlıklı çocuklar için bu uygun
dediler işte Ben hayatımda ilk defa 30
yaşında yaptığım planları aksiye
bileceğini öğrendim O gün o tombi
biberonlar öğretti bana hayatın
planlarından ibaret olmayacağını her
şeyi kontrol edemeyeceği mi ajandamı
bazı Yaprakların boş Black alabileceğine
Hayatımın en zor dönemini yaşıyorum İş
güç aklımdan çıkmıştı asla odamda
değildim
Şimdi benim gibi benim Yaşadığım şeyleri
birilerini anlatmam lazım Bunları
birileriyle paylaşmam lazım diye
düşünerek sosyal medyada bir hesap
açmaya karar verdim bana hayatımı
planlardan ibaret olmadığını öğreten
otom biberonların adını verdim hesabıma
iki Tom bir hayat dedim
Bu benim gibi pek çok insanla konuştukça
ferahlığı adım onlarla konuştukça
normalleşti bir yandan da bebeklerimiz
İyileşti
şimdi Doğum İznim bitti kurumsal hayata
yeniden döndüm görüşmeler toplantılar
sunumlar sürekli çalan telefonlar
Kariyerim oldukça iyi gidiyordu ama ben
yaptığım işte bir türlü dengede
olmadığımı hissediyorum
Şu hep aklımda biri var ama bu biri bir
yabancı değil yeni bir ben benim bundan
çok daha iyi bir Halime kavuşma hevesim
Ben her gün
Ama bu gittiğim geldiğim düzen
içerisinde bir çıkış yolu bulmam
gerektiğini hissediyordum
şey kendimi en Kent
kendimi mutlu hissettiğim yerse kurduğum
sofralarda tencerelerde yemek yapıp tüm
fındıkları çağırıyordu bakıyordum ki
tıpkı benim gibi herkesin en mutlu
olduğu yer sofralar Herkes diyor içiyor
sohbet ediyor oturan bir türlü Kalkmak
istemiyor bu sırada aklımda hep
anneannemin sahur sofraları annemin
günleri kardeşimle okuldan döndükten
sonra yediğimiz çikolatalı ekmek var
sohbet var kahkaha var Keyif var bu
mutluluğu yaymalıyız Peki nasıl İşte o
zaman o ilk gençlik yıllarındaki
hayalime geri dönüyorum bir şey üretme
ürettiğim şeyi fiziken görmem ve Fatmam
lazım benim en mantıklısı yemek satmam
lazım benim Peki bu yemek hangi yemek
hangi yemek her türlü insanı bir araya
getirebilir a o sesi ile torunu birlikte
ne yiyerek daha mutlu olabilirler diye
düşünüp duruyorum
bu ayrımı olmaksızın herkesin seveceği
bu şeyin tost olduğuna karar veriyor
çünkü
şühü herkes tosi var
Üstelik Tostçu açmak bütçemiz içinde
oldukça uygun eşimle birlikte kenara
ayırdığımız kaybedersek bizi
zorlamayacak bir miktar riski edebilirim
bu bebekleri büyütmesi sürecimiz boyunca
Annem sıklıkla desteğimiz de geliyor iş
hayatı ile ilgili o sıkılganlık ından
mutsuzluğumdan sürekli dalgınlığından
çok şikayetçiyim bir akşam kendisiyle
konuşurken bir şekilde lafa giriyorum
Hadi ben bir Tostçu açayım Ne dersin
diyorum annem şok olmuş vaziyette
suratıma bakıyor kızım hadi esnaflığı
anladık da bari İtalyan restoranı falan
açsaydın Bunca Yıldır seni okuttuk
Tostçu olacaksın diyor
bebeklerimiz bir buçuk yaşındalar gece
de belki on sefer uyanıyorlar
birbirine uyutuyorum diğer uyanıyor
diğerini uyutuyorum diğeri uyanıyor ve
ben bazen Nasıl olsa birazdan yeniden
uyanacağım diye uykuya dalmaya gerek
bile duymuyorum o geceler boyunca
Sürekli düşünüyorum Bir Tostçu açacağız
Ama nasıl ne şekilde açacağız benzer iş
yapan diğer herkesten ayrışmaları
heyecanlı olmalı enerjik olmadı keyifli
olmalı geçmişinizden izler taşıması ama
şimdi de kucaklamalı
bu işte böyle bir gibi gecede yine
kucağında yeniden uykuya dalsın diye
kızımı pişiriyorum bir yandan da ertesi
gün yine iş yerine gidip nasıl günü
sadece bitirmek için yaşayacağımı
düşünüp hüzünleniyorum o sırada aklıma
bir fikir geliyor
Yarın sabah olduğunda
ne yapsam Nereye gitsem beni mutlu eder
Mesela bir tost yasam
Ama bu tostun üzerinde bir mesaj yazsa
bunu görsen bana iyi gelir mi
bu Örneğin önüme gelen posta Her zamanki
gibi harika görünüyorsun imzabirtost
yazsa utanmasam evreka diye bakacaktım
Sanki dün sandığın tüm sorunlarına
çözümü bulmuş çatı heyecanlı uyandırdım
uykusu oldukça ağır olan eşime çok hızlı
anlatmaya başladım bir Tostçu açacağız
Çünkü postu herkes sever kadını erkeği
genci yaşlısı Hepsi gelir açık mutfaklar
da en kaliteli malzemeleri Tıpkı evdeki
gibi yapacağız Paketlerin her birinde
bir mesaj yazacak komik esprili samimi
menüyü gören gülümseyecek ürüne
geldiğinde yeniden gülümseyecek ve
fotoğrafını çekip sosyal medyada
paylaşacak bizi kısa zamanda herkes
duyacak
eşim şok olmuş bir vaziyette Bir gözü
açık bir gözü kapalı bana bakıyordu Ve
şöyle söyledi Tamam açarız Ama şu an
Saat Gecenin üçü şimdi uyuyalım Lütfen
sabah açarız da
bir karar verdiğinizde durduğunuz O
noktada ki en iyi durum Artık bir karar
vermiş olmanız bana göre yani Oo Konfor
alanınızın dışına çıkıp artık kararlı
olduğunuzda ilk ferahlama geliyor peki
yapmaya cesaret etmek İşte o çıkış
anında en çok anlam yüklenen kelime
cesaret
kendini o
uçurumdan o duvardan aşağı atmadan bir
nefes önce başka bir Sensin aslında bir
nefes sonraysa çok daha özgür bir sen
var
O çok fazla anlam yüklediğin cesaret
kelimesinin içerisindeki boşlukları fark
ettiğinde ise
Ama artık her şey mümkün ve inanmak Zor
Değil
Ben katıldığım bir forumda Eğitmenin
anlattığı bir hikaye beni çok
etkilemişti maske irlanda'da eğitim çok
önemli fakir köylü çocukların hepsi
saatlerce yürüyorlar yürüyerek
kasabalardaki okullara gidiyorlar okul
üniforması Tıpkı soyluların ki gibi
kumaş pantolon ceket gömlek ve bir şapka
bu şapkaya gözleri gibi bakıyor çocuklar
bu
bu maceralar yaşamayı seven iki öğrenci
o uzun yollardan giderken Derelerden Su
kıyılarından geçerken sürekli
kendilerine yeni bir hikaye uyduruyorlar
şimdi zaman bir asker oluyorlar kimi yaş
zaman dağda yaşayan bir Amway sürekli
birbirlerini motive ediyorlar var ne
zaman ki karşılarına aşılması çok zor
bir engel çıksın Örneğin büyük bir su
birikintisi veya çok yüksek bir duvar
İşte o zaman ilk önce şapkalarını
atıyorlar karşı tarafa şapka kıymetli
şapka önemli şapkayı almadan eve dönemez
ertesi günü okula gidemezler İşte o
şapka uğruna aşıyorlar tüm engelleri bu
değilim İngilizce yerleşiyor şapkayı
duvarın ötesini atmak bu işte kendine
bir büyük Hedef belirler Sen bir itici
güç O zaman
o zaman bu hayalimi gerçekleştirmek için
artıkk her şey hayallerinin tamamını
gerçekleştirmek artık mümkün
Bu benim için işte o anlattığım gece
başladı macera
sabah kalktığımda kafamda Neredeyse her
şey hazırdı hedefin belli hayallerim
gerçek koku kurumsal hayatın Beni yoran
rutinlerin Den ve rekabetçiliğin den
uzak
inisiyatifin ve heyecanı mutluluğu sınır
tanımadığı acil bir ortamda gülümseyerek
çalışan ekip üyeleri ile birlikte
keyifli ve lezzetli bir deneyim yaşamak
isteyen misafirlerimizi ağırlıyoruz 2017
ekiminden biri
Birlik dükkanları mızda sıklıkla değişen
Masalar dolusu insan heyecanı mızdan
enerjimiz den etkilenip çehresini
değiştiriyor
şu kendimin bundan daha iyi bir
versiyonu yaratmak için çıkmıştım bu
yola belki ama zamanla bana katılan
bugün hala beraber çalıştığımız ailem
arkadaşlarım ve ekip üyeleri ile
birlikte mi O denizin yüzünde tebessüm
oluşturmayı başardık
Selam bugün 4 şubemizde ayda 20 bin
misafir ağırlayarak
Bu enerji saçmaya devam ediyoruz Ben üç
çocuklu annelik maceramı
pıh Ergün iş hayatı ile ilgili kurduğum
hayallerimi kendini gerçekleştirmesi ve
beni mi sürekli değişti gelişen gelişimi
sosyal medyadan beni takip etmeye değer
bulanlara anlatmayı sürdürüyorum
Mutluluk veren tost annemizin
enerjisinin yayılması ve sizlere ilham
olması dileğiyle şapkanızı atıp
duvarlarınızı açmaya Hazırsanız
Mucizeler Çok yakında da